what's up marvel fans i'm joined by
paula newsom how's it going it's going
great this is terribly exciting no we
don't know too much about your character
what's it like joining the mcu you know
what i'm gonna tell you that
when twitter started kind of going to
gog they thought i was mj's mama not to
say that i'm not you know what i'm
saying but what's really fun about this
is joining this it's like
coming into halftime when the when the
game's already going and you jumping in
it's like i got to keep up i got gotta
keep up i gotta keep up it's fabulous
yeah well i bet you did amazing so
everyone knows that peter parker is
spider-man uh how does your character
feel about that
you know she's not so enthused by him
i'm not gonna give away too much and
that's the tea
that's true she doesn't much like him
that much because he's not impressed
i mean what do you got what do you got
whoa
okay i i'm taking that i'm gonna keep
that i'm gonna hold that while i go into
the theaters
what are you excited to see tonight
i'm excited to see the movie in its
entirety john watts our director is
amazing i got to work with an amazing
group of actors fred molina
tom you know we were there for a month
in the middle of atlanta just
i'm along with my stunt double it was
just i look forward to seeing the whole
thing you know the whole multiverse vibe
come on now
i mean you chose a great time to show up
i'm just saying well i don't want to
keep you you have the rest of the red
carpet to go and enjoy the film
congratulations again thanks love
[Music]
you